ciao mariners e benvenuti in un
nuovissimo vere
oggi parliamo di mamme ma in un modo
particolare
oggi vi farò scoprire quelli che sono i
significati più nascosti delle frasi che
dicono più spesso le nostre mamme te lo
avevo detto di sistemare camera tua che
cosa è questo è e questo è questo
momento è quello non hai sistemato
camera tuo e non pensare assolutamente
che lo faccia io per te va verso sai
cosa faccio io prendo e me ne vado da
questa casa voglio proprio vedere se
sopravvivere senza di me non me ne andrò
mai da questa casa quindi siate
riconoscenti per quello che faccio per
questa famiglia la serenità di signorina
è questa casa non è un albergo va bene
non puoi entrare e uscire agli orari che
preferisci
e non è neanche giusto che tu non vi è
una mano e che ti faccia servire perché
io non sono una cameriera è pronto è
pronta la scena allora che dobbiamo fare
è pronto vieni subito a dare una mano a
parecchia non so poi qualcosa è no non è
pronto è quasi pronto quando io avevo la
tua età mi comportavo come te forse è
anche peggio ma non te lo dirò mai
perché io ti devo dare il buon esempio
causa mia regola è mia
finché vivrà e sotto questo tetto fai
quello che ti dico io quando te ne
andrai continuerai a fare quello che ti
dico io perché io sono tua madre tu non
è sepolto a basta tutti i giorni al
telegiornale non si sa in tono altro che
disgrazie io non voglio che ti succede
niente e quindi preferisco che tu stia a
casa qui con me e fammi capire se i tuoi
compagni se mutasse da un burrone cosa
fai lo fai pure duo ho paura che i tuoi
compagni ti possono influenzare
negativamente poi portato un cane in
casa mia ma sei pazzo io ai due minuti
due minuti per portarlo fuori di qui a
casa migliaia i mari non entrano va bene
non bastava il lavoro che faccio tutti i
giorni per tenere pulita in ordine
questa casa ci mancava solo il cane a
raddoppiare la mia mole di lavoro in
realtà sappiamo tutti che dopo qualche
giorno si innamorerà del cane e si
premerà più cura del cane che di tutto
il resto della casa
in classe
e non sai cucinare e non sai la pare non
sai si sa non sai fare niente quale
poverino quello che chi sposa
proprio così povero quello che ti
sposerà per chi avrà una suocera come me
e io nonostante tutto sono tua madre
quindi sarò sempre dalla tua parte
tanti auguri ascoltami è per il tuo bene
è semplicemente quello che ho deciso
cosa hai detto non ora vedo bene faccio
finta di non aver sentito ai tre secondi
esatti per chiedermi scusa e rimangiarsi
quello che hai detto a me non interessa
che avuto ha preso gli altri va bene ti
devi impegnare di più perché io sono tua
madre e so che puoi fare di meglio
questa è l'ultima volta che te lo dico
te lo ripeterò per tutta la vita e se lo
trovo cosa succede come al solito non
hai cercato bene bene a posto fai quello
che vuoi
non pensare minimamente di farlo se no
come ti ho creato ti distruggo eccoci
arrivati alla fine del video cari
mariners spero che vi sia piaciuto e mi
raccomando fatemi sapere con un commento
qua sotto quali fra tv dicono di spesso
le vostre mamme e se non l'avete ancora
fatto
iscrivetevi subito al canale di marina e
cliccate sulla campanella vicino a tasse
di iscrizione e soprattutto seguitela su
tutti gli altri soci quindi instagram
facebook è che i topi vi mando un
bacione
mi raccomando fate i bravi a non ve lo
dico più
ciao
[Musica]